ازمه المناخ قضيه عادله الا ان اساليب
احتجاج ناشط البيئه تتخطى الحدود وتؤدي
الى العديد من الحوادث التخريبيه وصل
بعضها الى حادثه موت متظاهره في برلين تحت
عجلات شاحنه بعد ان اغلقت المظاهره طريقا
عاما
اساليب متنوعه اتبعتها تنظيمات مدافعه عن
البيئه الفن كان الهدف الاول حالات تعد
على لوحات عالميه تبلغ قيمتها ملايين
الدولارات
صلصه طماطم تحول اللون الاصفر للوحه دوار
الشمس لفان جوخ الى الاحمر وبطاطا مهروسه
تنساب على اكوام قش كلود مونيه والنشطاء
يلصقون انفسهم بلوحه الفتاه ذات القرط
اللؤلؤي
واخرها لوحه للفنان الاسباني فرانسيسكويا
في متحف برادو في مدريد تظهران في مقطع
فيديو وقد قام الرجل وامراه من جماعه
بيئيه بالصاق ايديهما باللوحتين مع
عبارتين تحمل الرقم درجه ونصف مئويه وهي
الحد المتفق عليه عالميا لزياده في درجه
حراره الارض وفقت اتفاقيه باريس للمناخ في
[موسيقى]
وبالتزاملي مع انعقاد قيمه المناخ كوب
سبعه وعشرين في شرم الشيخ تزايدت
الاحتياجات البيئيه بمختلف اشكالها ليتجمع
عدد من الناشطين في مطار في امستردام في
مظاهره نظمتها جرين كيس واكستن ريبليون في
ملابس بيضاء جالسين امام عجلات الطائرات
يمنعوها من الاقلاع لساعات بحجه ان المطار
اكبر مصدر الانبعاثات ثاني اكسيد الكربون
بالرغم من ان المطار يتطلعوا الى ان يصبح
خاليا من الانبعاثات بحلول عام 2030 الى
عمر العربيه